Being a standup comedian is one of the
hardest jobs in the entertainment
industry,
if not the hardest job in the
entertainment industry,
and it takes a special skill and a
special talent to be able to do that,
to be up there on a stage,
just you and a microphone and a stool
and be able to be so open and
vulnerable,
you know,
you hear stories.
I'm comedians are more depressed,
they have more substance abuse,
they have more of this,
more of that and you know,
they're just a really,
really troubled
population and I,
I don't necessarily think they're more
trouble than anybody else.
The lifestyle of a standup comedian
breeds the depression,
um,
or it can exacerbate something that's
preexisting,
like a bipolar disorder or substance
abuse because what happens is that they
are out on the road and they are by
themselves and they're traveling
sometimes to these areas that aren't
very popular and aren't very pretty and
working in these dark,
Dank clubs and then going back to a
dark,
Dank
hotel room and it gets very,
very lonely.
They don't have their support system.
They don't have much of anything.
They're there by themselves,
so when you're bored,
you're going to find something to
entertain yourself with like alcohol or
drugs.
And that's,
um,
that's when the problems start to
persist and then it goes on and on and
on from there.
Um,
until they get treatment,
comedians do see comedy as a sort of
self treatment.
A lot of times they think of it as their
therapy.
The problem is,
is that being onstage and performing and
doing your,
your standup a,
it's not therapy.
It is definitely therapeutic,
but it is not therapy.
There is that a thought that
if you are successful,
if you make more money,
if you are admired,
um,
if you're recognized out on the street
that all your problems are going to go
away.
That is not true.
And again,
as we saw with Robin Williams,
his problems did not go away.
Um,
your problems just become different.
they become,
um,
different levels of stress,
different levels of depression,
and it's across the board.
If you don't deal with your mental
health,
um,
it,
it's not going to go away.
There is a stigma across the board still
with mental health.
Um,
we think that,
um,
we can't solve our own problems and if
we go seek help by talking to a
therapist,
psychologist,
psychiatrist,
any other mental health worker that
there is a problem with us that there
were,
were crazy or something like that.
So I think we'll end can be a useful
resource in terms of,
um,
teaching the world about mental health
issues when you come out publicly and
deal with any sort of issue on a certain
level,
um,
and talk about it as if it is just
something that is not stigmatized,
then we won't look at it as something
that is bad or evil.
I think what we need to start doing is
really looking at mental health as any
other medical condition that we all
experience.
You know,
we have a pain in our knee,
pain in our back.
We have diabetes,
we have a heart condition.
We go to a doctor or take medication,
eat right exercise,
do what we need to do,
follow through with that.
And um,
and we start getting better.
Hopefully.
Well,
that's the same thing with mental
health.